thank you dig it refers to a two verse
salads the first one at the first exit
first I can't remember but I believe you
were the first one to get the first had
two verse only you know how many tattoos
I think I like more than 40 tattoos I'm
like the poster child for like the
people who got tats before they had like
a full-functioning mind and now I'm like
looking myself I should have laid it and
I could have did some really great first
tattoo I was 14 years old my first
tattoo is when I was in like ninth grade
growing up I used to love watching a
live person play basketball and you know
he always had tattoos I felt like all my
favorite basketball players head tattoos
Furman get everything his artwork is
crazy and I'm the rest kid what looking
to him it was it's nuts I got my first
tattoo I was 18 this is the first one I
got this line I'm a Leo so it kinda
makes sense and then on the back kind of
transitions into like a basketball took
like three hours and it was like the
most painful thing ever I got my first
tattoo about a year and a half ago Ryan
Lewis was going to get a tattoo and he
was like don't just do it and I had held
out my entire life
and then finally I was like okay I'll
get this clover on my finger I'm Irish
clover finger tat went there and the
clover is definitely not centered
whatsoever and that lasted me like a
couple months but the next two opened up
the floodgates wanted to get it to two
and I got it when I was 14 years old I
have it here in my leg and my left leg
is the is my name is my luma and if you
guys don't know my luma is because my
mom's name is Margie my dad's name is
Louise and my sister's name is Manuela
so I took the first two letters of each
name my mom she she got super mad with
me but when she saw the meaning of my
tattoo she was like oh my god it's too
big but I'm gonna stepped it because
it's your family then I got this when I
was 14 man honestly it's the I had the
tiger
I just went hard the first time we're
basically in a hotel
the dude was like drinking is late he
was like doing on tape we was getting
held a test for real cheap this is
probably like one of my newest those
tattoos I got I'm not touching my face
face it's that hot Kourt yeah that's so
much my mom she would I never plan on
like Ted in my face I don't [ __ ] with
that I feel like I like my face I woke
up with these tattoos this says get cake
die young I woke up with it I had no
idea I'd even got it I was so [ __ ] up
I literally was just like alright that's
there
my mom's name in my face Shelby yes like
my favorite one
she kept trying to get me to stop
getting face tats but then I was like
I'm gonna get one more says she couldn't
really saved my family when I got this
21 I was with layer that's my brother
Claire
that was my first faith tattoo but he
died so I went he got RFP layer around
the 21 said this r.i.p on top and Larry
on the bottom you know when he got block
boy right here then I got death before
dishonor right and then my liver look
right at a man died and I got the nice
tattoo right here
if it's on my face is deep anywhere else
that's different well on my face it
gotta stand for something I found myself
complaining a lot being very ungrateful
for the thing about having my life so I
got the crybaby tattoo on my face to
remind me that I'm really good they'd
already drew this in London for like an
exhibition and I decided that I would
get it tattooed on me in London your
head really is not that bad but the
further it gets towards the back just
like well she they don't feel like no
peach they're like
rest of them know her like that and just
I hate cuz it's like the school it I
really know me right now my next tat I'm
gonna finish this one so I had this
piece on right here but just wanna hurt
so I didn't finish it it was super
painful in the shin my I guess an Ummah
cream coordinator hi
it just got I'm a girl like her boobs
and [ __ ] out I'm thinking about getting
the color then just cuz like it's big
[ __ ] but I think it will look at your
color but it's gonna take like five
hours so that's why I've been like the
baton and [ __ ] cuz I'm like do that
again just painful bro that's something
people like oh you like intact I do but
it hurts Brian go alright I learned
something by myself because bro you're
going through pain for real especially
this [ __ ] I'm getting dug about armpits
it all these buildings and should I just
got at it everything was all at once all
of that [ __ ] my favorite ex is my tights
on my back it's a peacock I got it
approximately four months ago it
shouldn't crazy took about six hours in
a hurry we're like a mob [ __ ] what it
was worth potatoes was feeling great all
over
I love getting tattoos I think it's just
a minute there some hurt more than
knowledge most painful tattoo for me was
my fingers I got free TC you know my
first album fast everybody from my squad
has this because we get everything fast
you know we also all have pushes anybody
that's a real ty dolla sign saying you
got to be a fan of DJ mustard you got to
be a fan of yg and there's about a
thousand of us they had this person you
know a pretty deep fire if I had to
choose a favorite it'll be just angel my
neck I got a nice big angel like this
like
they don't allow this is one of my
favorites it's just my believe my
eternal mood it's really low quality but
that's because my mood is low quality
you know anything most people were to
get this but this is like one of my
favorite hats so got my favorite
customer right here it says [ __ ] I got a
mortal right here I'm [ __ ] not from
this planet through hop a lot of
portraits take on this arm my mother my
daughter my grandma my pops my
grandfather - costs all of us will rest
in peace
all these portraits are those are
definitely my favorite my family you
know went this means a lot to me from
everybody you know is that you know I
love Flint I have a lot of religious
tattoos on my body
these birds symbolize new beginnings
don't was art when the flood came she
sent out Doug to go fight land they came
back with branches some praying hands
one of my favorite references Nipsey
Hussle
he has to say TMC and that means the
marathon for two years my life has been
a marathon without anniversary down face
so you know just reading these Watson I
got the old it means wisdom for me is
like one of the most important tattoos I
get because instead to a super spiritual
tool because like a kind of protection
all these bad vibes and bad energies
that are around the world and I feel
like these two to help me a lot like
trying to control it
you know I don't think there's really
one particular style but if I had to
choose my favorite it would probably be
like oh those tile factories I Fisher
I've loved American traditional tattoos
for a long time I feel like everyone was
getting American traditional tattoos
like in the mid thousands was like the
hipster birth coming out of Seattle and
I always liked those tattoos but I
wanted to make sure that this wasn't
like some trend that I was in two years
gonna be like no I'm into this now and
with me at last I always loved the
tattoo is it never shifted and so when I
started I wanted to keep it all American
traditional I get tattoos
because for me they're reminders
reminders of things in my life were
things I've accomplished or wish to
accomplish tattoos tell your life story
it our like remind me of a time I what
was going on in my life at that point of
time when I when I need to fill in the
space I love my tattoo artist like I let
him come up with the idea but like the
big pieces are you could tell like this
well-thought-out pieces I come up with
you're gonna get a lot of taxes you
something right did at least get what
you represent like you know your people
around you we really care about our room
from
this one is one of my favorite tattoos
this is 2013 cherry this is a street in
Seattle but it's my fellowship hall for
my recovery this is my home this is
where I got sober what keeps me sober
this is big for me
this is my newest tattoo like a
spaceship you in the movie Michael was
struggling and bugs hand him Space Jam
juice they said Michaels
super stuff but I don't want Michael on
my body so I changed it comes to secret
stuff
I got p.m. a positive ID attitude a
little back of my neck and neck somebody
get the big guys a little go right here
always go back and get a like right
before his season so mad my tap man come
to Boston I suppose I set her down I'll
do something crazy on her back once you
started writing anything in life is just
like Pandora's box of her great that's
why you just keep getting tattoos though
like I don't ever think about the clover
that I used to obsess about everything's
fine everything was placed chalk it up
enjoy it and get some more I kind of
like looking like a mess and just like
what the [ __ ] if you're thinking about
it do it and if you like how people look
when they're all covered in tattoos and
you should be covered in tattoos if I
woke up and I didn't have any of my
tattoos on I would cry for like an hour
I advise if you want to get tattoos just
ask your mom before you get face tattoos
because that's the face that she gave
you
[Music]